when we think about alien civilizations
we tend to look into the vastness of
space to far away planets
but there is another incredibly vast
dimension that we might be giving too
little thought to
time
could it be that over the last hundreds
of millions of years other civilizations
existed on earth
indigenous technological species that
rose and died out and that they or their
artifacts are buried beneath our feet
what does science have to say about this
and what are the implications for us
[Music]
life on earth has existed for four
billion years mostly as single-celled
organisms until some 540 million years
ago the cambrian explosion heralded the
age of animals
a huge time window for our indigenous
aliens
where would we look for them and what
could we hope to find
sadly we have only one civilization to
look at ourselves
anatomically modern humans emerged
around 300 000 years ago and probably
lived in small groups of
hunter-gatherers slowly spreading around
the world
progress was slow and our lifestyle
didn't change much although there may
have been local bursts of complexity
until about 10 000 years ago when the
agricultural revolution changed our
lifestyle forever enabling massive
population growth and technological
progress
rather than just animals with culture
and tools that would have been invisible
from space we changed the face of the
planet cleared forests and constructed
cities and temples for our gods at
breathtaking speeds and scales
until about 300 years ago we became an
industrial species and yet again our
numbers grew exponentially as did our
impact on the planet
we could say that our three hundred
thousand year long history has three
phases
we were hunter-gatherers for 97 farmers
for 2.9 percent and industrialists for
0.1 percent of our history
and yet we are super new on earth
on geological time scales even the
sturdiest things lose their durability
the oldest large-scale surface is the
negev desert omega 1.8 million years old
everything older has been crushed to
dust or turned over and it's either
below the ground or covered by ice or
ocean
our age the anthropocene will be a layer
only a few centimeters thick in a few
million years
if there were aliens before us and they
too went through these three phases what
would remain of them what can we learn
about indigenous aliens by looking at
ourselves
hunter-gatherer aliens
we actually know that in the last few
million years there were hunter-gatherer
aliens our ancestors like homo erectus
and cousins like the neanderthals or
dennis ovens and probably many more that
we haven't found yet or are lost to time
forever
they left fragments of their bodies of
weapons and tools and even art
considering how long they existed and
how little remains of them although they
live not that far from our present it's
easy to think there have been others
intelligent animals like us that could
talk and use tools and fire that had
culture and art
for the last two million years most
hominins lived as hunter-gatherers so if
these aliens never moved up higher on
the tech tree hundreds of different
species and cultures could have existed
without leaving any traces their
artifacts lost to biological and then
geological processes
at worst they would leave absolutely
nothing to be found after thousands of
years
but what about fossils
we talked about how unlikely the process
of fossilization is in more detail in
our dinosaur video but in a nutshell per
hundred thousand years of earth's
history we only get a handful of good
fossils
so we might easily just miss fossils of
such people but even if we had any we
wouldn't necessarily be able to identify
them as hunter-gatherers
agricultural and empire aliens
looking at humans again agricultural
societies left much more to be dug up
and found because they used more
sophisticated tools made from sturdier
materials and had to feed millions
leaving many more artifacts
farming allowed them to specialize and
develop tech from writing to navigation
architecture and government
over thousands of years city-states
became kingdoms and empires some
existing for millennia before they fell
many of the buildings or monuments they
constructed are still around and traces
of them will exist for a few thousand
more years
some only as outlines in the ground but
still recognizable to future
archaeologists
the pyramids are piles of limestone so
massive that they will probably be
around for hundreds of thousands of
years
and because of the greater numbers of
humans that live during our farm and
empire period we can expect way more
fossils and artifacts to be detectable
maybe for a few million years before
they vanish so we can say with
confidence that no such indigenous alien
civilization existed in the last few
million years because otherwise we would
have found something that they left
this still leaves a window of hundreds
of millions of years back to the
emergence of complex life where we
wouldn't be able to tell
if there were alien pre-industrial
societies and empires on the level of
the ancient romans or chinese they would
have likely disappeared without a trace
their tools even advanced metals would
have rotted away if they dug up canals
cleared forests and built cities their
traces would be very hard to distinguish
from nature
maybe there was once an empire of
cephalopods occupying impressive cities
in swamps and lakes made from wood and
stone
their engineers flooding land to build
wet cities their poets reciting poems in
a language of colours
maybe they never industrialized
maybe their society was too stable or
not inventive enough or they never got a
chance
a single event like an asteroid an
epidemic or an ice age could just have
deleted their civilization ground up
their temples as their soft bodies
rotted away
sadly we don't have the tiniest amount
of evidence for any such civilization
after a few million years at best their
achievements would have dissolved into
nothing
industrial indigenous aliens
what about industrial civilizations like
humanity today
imagine humans died out suddenly through
a pandemic or cosmic rays or something
like that
what would remain
our impact on the planet is orders of
magnitude greater than that of our
ancestors the fossil record will show a
great extinction of wildlife and an
explosion of fossils from human
associated animals like rats cows pigs
and chickens
like the structures of our ancestors
skyscrapers and streets and hard drives
will basically crumble into nothingness
in a few millennia
but because there were so many humans
everywhere for a few million years after
our sudden end there would be clear
hints of our existence
the byproducts of our industrial
lifestyle might actually give us away
for some hundreds of millions of years
we use massive amounts of artificial
fertilizer which redirects earth's flow
of nitrogen that is being deposited in
the soil
mining metals and rare earth elements
leaves long-term scars and depletes
natural resources
we saturate our oceans with plastics
that find their way to the ocean floor
and may persist for hundreds of millions
of years
there are radioactive elements and their
decay unnatural accumulations of
elements that don't exist outside labs
or weapons
and of course in our short industrial
history we have changed the proportion
of co2 in the air by burning massive
amounts of fossil fuels increasing the
acidity of the oceans and so on
we may already have left a mark in the
geological record
so far we have found no traces of an
industrial alien civilization
no layers of weird chemicals or
displaced elements no radioactive layer
to indicate that once great nations
waged nuclear war
we do see mass extinctions and massive
shifts in the fossil records but no
evidence that they did not occur
naturally
and ironically we've hit upon an
interesting problem here if industrial
societies stress the ecosystem enough to
cause their own extinction they won't be
around that long
but if they become sustainable their
imprint on the geological record may be
tiny
if past industrial civilizations were
sustainable before they died out we may
have little to no chance of ever knowing
about them
in any case over hundreds of millions of
years these signatures may become very
subtle and get overlooked or interpreted
as natural
even if an industrialized alien society
existed 200 million years ago and lasted
for 100 000 years 300 times longer than
industrial humanity it still might be
easy to miss it in the geological record
in any case all of this is speculation
in the end we shouldn't use our
imagination to trick ourselves into
thinking we know anything about our
blind spots
just assuming a thing happened because
we don't have evidence against it is a
trap we should avoid
so for now if we look at the vastness of
time it seems as devoid of aliens as the
vastness of space
maybe we are alone in this universe and
always were
maybe we'll find traces of others
eventually we don't know
but there is one important takeaway the
continuation of our civilization is not
guaranteed and if we're not careful we
may disappear forever
let's hope that in a few million years
there isn't another civilization
studying our layer in the fossil record
it's frustrating to know there are so
many things in our past we can't access
at least you can avoid that annoying
feeling when it comes to other stuff
you're interested in like your favorite
tv shows or movies you can make this
possible by going to nordvpn.com
not vpn service lets you change your
virtual location by choosing from over
5200 fast servers in 60 countries all
over the world and access regionally
blocked content or games that may not be
available in your country
secure your internet traffic with top
tier nordvpn encryption no matter if
you're using a computer tablet or
smartphone it's compatible with every
major platform and can be used on six
devices at once
if you want to make the rest of your
digital life airtight as well nordvpn
also offers the secure password manager
nordpass and encrypted cloud storage
nordlocker to explore all the games and
shows you can get your hands on go to
nordvpn.com for an exclusive deal for
our viewers it's risk free with
nordvpn's 30 day money back guarantee
[Music]
great
[Music]